[Music]
hi I'm here with King boy today who is a
Finnish educator and she's also the lady
that got me into the fitness industry
ten years ago so Kim many people knew
you as a Finnish educator but there's
another side of the story that people
don't know about which is why we're here
today to talk about postpartum
depression so before we even talk about
your side of the story can you let us
know more about what is postpartum
depression okay so I was just told the
other day that it's not called
postpartum depression anymore
it's called peripartum depression and
what it means is that it's depression
that's caused that a woman has when
she's pregnant
or she might have after she's had a baby
okay and so what are some of the
symptoms okay well I guess I should
state clearly that I'm not doctor I'm
not a psychiatrist or psychologist and
the symptoms do vary but for me the
symptoms were after having my baby so I
was 38 when I had my first baby and I
remember one week in just lying on the
sofa and crying and I was staying with
my mom at the time and she didn't know
why and and and just things were just so
black like I was trying to breastfeed
because breastfeeding is the best thing
to give your baby I had no idea how to
breastfeed I bought a pump and I was
like nursing and trying to squeeze milk
turning the pump right up it was just
the wrong thing to do and it just seemed
like the whole cycle was just baby baby
stay in the house cannot go out like I
lost my life lost control
so I guess symptoms were feeling sad
feeling no way out feeling like I wanted
to like give the baby bag but you kind
of course and then eventually it was
insomnia couldn't sleep at night and I
remember the beat my first baby used to
cry and cry and cry especially at night
so when night fell I would feel like my
the hairs on my skin just like starting
to rise up okay
and just for the audience to know this
is something that Kim has never spoken
openly about so you're here today
because you feel that this is an
important topic to reach out to the
other women out there who might be going
through it but they're not aware of it
correct yes actually two reasons the
first one actually is is for myself
because I think a lot I I don't talk
about this so people don't know this
about me and I've kind of feel like I'm
living a lie
mm-hmm because this is a part of who I
am and like I said only a few people of
my family and my friends know about it
and I don't speak about it openly
I guess cuz I'm ashamed I'm I I you know
it's postpartum depression so it's it's
like I'm a bad mother but why I mean
were you ashamed or I you still a shame
right now do you think I think there's a
lot of stigma with depression and more
so with postpartum depression it happens
after you have a baby and if you see you
know if you see social media and you see
after mother gives birth she said oh
happy and the baby smiling and googoo
gaga and the mothers are so so happy but
that wasn't the way it was for me so
yeah and because you're also portrayed
as a very strong figure being a fitness
educator you're always out there in
front of a lot of your students
and in a way you're a leader to them so
I guess for you to tell people this side
of your story it's not easy it's not
easy yeah and do you think it happened
to you because you're an older mom and
also do feel that there was a lack of
support yeah I would say have to be
honest I think it's my personality I'm a
perfectionist I have high expectations
of myself I beat myself up so when I
couldn't breastfeed rather than stopping
and turning to formula I kind of forced
forced it and then I would feel really
guilty and then all those caldas
personality traits and it was you know
support system as well and it was also
again my inability to ask for help
everything just like spiral and got
bigger a lot of issues laughs how long
did you go through that before you I
mean take me through the process how
long did you go through that before you
decided that you know what I'm going
through something that's not right I
need help and I want help you know it
wasn't it wasn't like that at all it was
just horrible because like I said before
it is the feeling of no control and then
the insomnia and the fear of the baby
and just the everything was so black I
felt like I lost myself and I remember
one night one night I was sleeping next
to my husband and I I wasn't sleeping
because I couldn't sleep and it was the
middle of night and I thought I'm going
to go to go to the kitchen I'm gonna
take a knife and I'm gonna kill myself
and I didn't think there was anything
wrong because I couldn't even think at
the point and then the next day my
husband took me to our gynecologist but
and she gave me more tips on how to
breastfeed but I think I think it was
already like too late for any of that
okay yeah and it just got worse and
worse and there was a visit to the
psychiatrist where he put me on a
questionnaire and I was like very very
very severe and he sent me back with
medication but when I got back I think I
gave the baby to my mom and I were not
off my apartment and I wanted to jump
who stopped you idiot my husband he
stopped you yeah did he I mean I'm just
trying to be in his shoes right now did
he understand what was going on no I
don't think anybody really knew how bad
it was yeah and Chris it's always our
first baby nobody knew yeah nobody knew
that yeah everybody was like just caught
by surprise and yeah and a few days
after that I remember there was a Sunday
morning my husband was at work I don't
know where the baby was I think with my
parents and I remember climbing to the
top floor of my condo and I stood at the
edge and I wanted to jump already and I
just I just
they just summoning the courage the
copmi has been and she was in class and
I told him I'm going to jump can she sit
wait I'll come and jump with you do you
really say that hmm sorry she just it's
okay it's okay seriously it's okay it
was admitted to the circuit board I've
been there three times what do you think
he'd say that he would come and jump
with you she didn't want me to jump okay
and that saved you mm-hmm and you came
back and then they admitted me do that
to you hitch my mum sit in the ambulance
with me she didn't know what was going
on
do you know what I think what you're I
mean I just I'm so grateful for you me
here today
because in a way you sharing all this
you're opening yourself up and you're
not hiding away anymore and I think your
story can be such a huge inspiration to
all the moms out there yeah because
you're here today right now and the
story you're telling us that was six
years ago am i right was seven years ago
yes yeah seven years ago and yeah you're
here I know yeah yeah yeah but it was
just the most horrible thing Wow yeah
you know you know yeah what did I do the
desert is and why me it's always the
stuff blame isn't it yeah yeah yeah okay
and then the fear right now but what
fear I mean did you at that point did
you still continue teaching no no I mean
the road to recovery was very long
mm-hmm
the first time I was in the psychiatric
ward for about ten days then when I came
out I mean had to deal with the fact
that I feel that breastfeeding
I had feel that bringing up my baby
maybe
he was sitting with my mother mm-hmm
it's a long process
it is like fight to get my baby back to
stick with me you mean my family didn't
trust me because I tried to kill myself
yeah yeah but I did you know like a few
months after that I was looking after my
baby I slowly got back to work the
second time with my second baby I wanted
a second baby because I wanted a
companion for my son I wanted a second
child
so I had the second baby you know I
didn't ask my husband I've been a hit
and got pregnant okay
yeah and I took a breastfeeding course
and everything was fine for three months
I breastfed successfully and then we
went to poke it and because I think deep
down I was still like I had a lot of
fear
I brought my pump and I couldn't pump my
milk out I was encouraged it's the same
trauma that has repeated anyway yes same
fear that same inability to control yeah
yep correct is spiral and then same
thing in Phuket I couldn't sleep
insomnia and I lay awake thinking I want
to end my life I want to end my life
because I think after the first time is
happen already so I'm at risk the first
if you have postpartum depression the
first time around you're at higher risk
to have it the second and second timer
yeah but did you feel that you were more
in control the second time because you
recognized the symptoms and things like
that I was in control the first three
months when I successfully breastfed but
I think all the other symptoms like you
know like my relationship my family
issues support issues were still there
you know so it was actually was the
second time around it was worse I only
spent I spent less time in the hospital
but I it was terrible I spent a longer
time feeling depressed every day and
that's just terrible yeah yep it's
terrible it's like a black hole you fall
in and you can't get out and at that
time did you look after two of your kids
no I was incapable incapable okay my my
parents my parents have stepped in to
help me every time this has happened
and you know you know my children will
my two boys will also grow up and I
can't hide this from them it's part of
who I am so that's why I'm doing this
too so I can be more open about it
rather than brushing it aside but it's
really hard because depression and
postpartum depression people just don't
talk about it
yeah especially in Asian countries I
would say very much
I mean people see it unfortunately
people it's too big taboo and people
just think that it's psychological
issues but it's not the case yeah so and
people don't seek help people don't seek
help sometimes they are not even aware
of it you're a fitness educator and
you're always surrounded by people and
you're someone that stays active all the
time as well do you think that Fitness
did Fitness help you at all basically no
nothing L didn't know so during the
darkest day of the days of depression
nothing helps it's very dark it's very
bleak I don't know how to describe it
because I don't know how to make someone
feel there's it to go through it
but one of the symptoms of depression is
losing interest and yeah I lost interest
in fitness although I love it lost
interest in my babies in my
relationships and food in it was
interest in everything laughs basically
you lost interest in everything that you
used to correct laughs yeah correct and
so that's one of the major symptoms to
look out for what was sort of like the
breakthrough because I understand that
from what you're telling me you had it
on in your first kit and then you
relapse again second time and just off
camera just now you told me that you
went through the third round of
depression so maybe you can take us
through that what was like a mini
breakthrough each time and how do you
cope with that there is no like breach
through there's no like one day when you
wake up and everything is fine again
it's not like that at all mm-hmm the
first and I will say this every time it
happened it was harder it was worse so
the second time was harder and longer
than the first time and the third time
was just stealing are you still dealing
with it right now you would say no I'm
recover fully recovered okay it just
takes time it takes time and medication
helps so I was on antidepressants and
then you have to go and see a
psychiatrist and as I or a psychologist
and personally for me the first second
even third time I would say that's part
of the process but what really helped me
was more I think mainly it was more
myself it just took time for me myself
to get better and of course having
friends that support me but even then
you know you can it's really hot for
friends and for family so if I
understand yeah it's really really hot
yeah they don't know why you're so down
they say things like your baby is so
cute you should be so grateful you've
got your parents yeah you're so lucky
you know look you know look you're such
a beautiful family but and then when
they say things that that I feel even
worse because it's like yeah why don't I
feel like that yeah
what's wrong with me yeah I mean like I
don't say this a lot but I do have a
really close family member who goes
through the depression as well and I
know how hard it can be because it's
always that perfectionism you know when
you don't think where you don't when
you're not able to do things well you
beat yourself up over it and you
question yourself why can I do is why
can it be better it's always a why can't
I moment and when other people tell you
that you should be this you should be
that it makes you a few worse so one of
the really important thing that I think
we all should start learning to stop
doing is we shouldn't tell people what
they should be or how they should be
because everybody has a different life
path everybody leads a different life
and everybody has a different story so
we shouldn't be so quick to judge others
because we're not in their shoes and
it's much much easier said than done
yeah yeah it's true you shouldn't judge
other moms you know you shouldn't moms
who choose not to breastfeed moms who
choose to have a c-section moms who
choose different ways of parenting they
want to homeschool their kids judgment
is lifelong once you start becoming a
mother and actually it happens it's
easier said
but really uh-oh people judge mothering
and parenting it's really tough it's
really tough these days the stress level
is so high we want the best for our kids
and people just should be more kind to
each other
yeah and so if a mother is watching this
right now and she feels that she's going
through postpartum depression or just
depression in general what would your
first advice be advisor yeah like is it
the sicker psychiatry straightaway no I
mean like I said that didn't really that
is the suggested path so for me it you
know it
I think the medication did help so yeah
I think my my advice would be like open
up you know open up and tell the people
who are closest to you okay and don't
feel bad about asking for help you know
never have a feel bad for asking for
help because you only get better through
that yeah it's just this is and it's not
easy to talk about it but the support
system is important correct whether it's
where your family or your friends we all
need that kind of support system because
you cannot go through this on your own
you cannot heal on your own in fact the
support system is very very important
and also I really wish that no other mom
would have to go through this because
it's just really really really horrible
but you know and what doesn't kill you
makes you stronger sounds corny but it's
actually true I'm still sitting here
after going through a very very horrible
experience and yeah there's no use lying
about or covering that these things
don't happen this this happen yeah so
what do you think could have happened to
you
if it has been left on treated untreated
well the worst-case scenario is if I had
the guts to actually carry out my
suicide attempts law that means I would
not be here today and could not get to
be with my kids and my family and my
friends and to enjoy life or what it is
for others
I mean you've I don't know whether
you've heard of the cases in America
where a woman has has killed her own
children and it's so easy when you've
not had depression it's so easy to read
that and to judge once again is that
she's bonkers you kill her own children
but I've gone through a depression and
know how hopeless in the situation is
really really hopeless there's no way
out
she probably acted because of that I'm
not saying that it's right but that was
she can't think rationally yeah yeah
okay do you think you could have done
something to change the situation at
that time you know what I had a close
friend who used to tell me come it's
used to run a mom and baby fitness
center she said come for talks on
postnatal depression you know because it
happens and I would listen to him and
think not me how can I get depression I
mean that's for weak people and that was
before you gave birth yeah that was
before I gave birth so and I don't think
anything could have been done to prevent
it and I don't choose to think that way
what I choose to think of now is like
it's a blessing because every day now
when I see my kids I think I have more
patience with them I appreciate them all
even when I do do things like drag them
to school I appreciate it
because I'm there with them I think I'm
a better mother because I've gone
through it yeah every every little small
things about them makes you appreciate
them rather than getting annoyed that's
right but those little things yeah
joyful moments correct yeah and I feel
like I've been given a second chance to
be a mom 'la so that's what I'm gonna do
that's amazing I think I mean I haven't
known you for I guess 10 years now since
I started and I I don't know this side
of your story at all so I just want to
thank you to really come here today to
just open up and because I know your
courage will be helping so many other
women out there and thank you I I mean
I'm excited to what's you know we'll be
coming next in your career in your
family life and I think things will only
get better thanks to it now thank you so
much Kim
thank you so much